he was known for having the biggest dick
in hollywood wasn't he did have the
biggest stick in hollywood well i'm
saying he was you saw it yeah
you've been to the oval office and
you've seen milton berle stick yeah how
did you see milton bros dick um we're at
the friars club
and i think he wanted me to see it
before he died
oh that's so touching it was very
touching and i felt really uh
he said that to you
not in so many words how what words did
he use i got a p can you help me
so i help him he's in a wheelchair no he
said i gotta pee will you help me yeah
what was your what was your i was like
you know i was a sweet guy that would
sit with him for hours and he just no no
i know i'm not he told me about fidel
castro sending him cigars and [ __ ] like
that no i get that but if somebody said
i have to pee would you help me i
wouldn't know what like what is what was
your job say no i probably oh get
somebody he was in a wheelchair
not because he couldn't walk but for his
[ __ ] it was
sometimes he used his own personal cane
sometimes he used the chairs so but did
you have to unzip him and pull out did
you did you handle his dick no no i peed
now i think he just wanted someone there
in case a buddy system a buddy system
like a spotter and you were able to pee
on like at the melton borough's going to
pee
i will pee all right so you just said
that the same problems do that all the
time no but he you did that to him you
know that when you said you had to pee i
almost went he almost went he's he said
he's a pure panic peer but i can't i
can't hold it because i've had kids
so you know you've got to do more giggle
i know okay you do like a second no
never no you got to do it i got to get
my my vagina has got to be tightened up
i don't think it's your vagina oh
is it is kegel kegel your your vagina
i think it's the muscle in
and i think that they tighten it up
because what happens is those muscles
are loosened when you have a child and
therefore sometimes when they laugh they
pee or when they sneeze they pee so if
you have trouble holding in your pee i
don't know that this is right but you do
kegel exercises and as a mat so do them
well you're here before the expression
comes or wasn't a dry seat in the house
how are you feeling
i i feel good let me finish i got to
finish go ahead he's peeing next to me
okay
and milton berle he knows it yeah and
i'm now i'm i you know i helped him up
and just make sure he's okay and while
he's doing i'm peeing
and
he leans back just enough to show me
that it's endless
wow endless this giant 90 year old penis
it's like a fleshy rainbow wait even
flaccid i think he wanted me to my
daughter's hat yeah
i think he wanted me to know how big it
was because we were roasting um can
jeremy animate that
we were roasting joe torrey the yankees
manager right and you know i wound up
having first-hand
account of how big milton's famous
penis was how big do you think it was um
it had a warning track
yeah it was gigantic but you think he
showed it to you oh for sure
that was his famous thing i'll take
let's have a a
did he did he look you in the eyes while
he leaned back um
i don't think it was that weird it
wasn't predatory it wasn't that weird it
was like come help me i want to show you
my dick that's like the word most [ __ ]
up gender reveal party i've ever
he also taught me how to smoke cigars
and talk what do you mean taught you how
i never smoked a cigar right so what did
you start with his dick
what did you what do you mean he taught
you how to smoke like you don't smoke
cigars any any any you know he
he took a a cigar out that he said fidel
castro
wow you know because he would play
cuba back in before
it was illegal yeah and
he took his cigar out he stuffed it and
held it in his nostril
and this is the guy that taught you how
to do it and he inhaled it he inhaled it
and he said if it smells like [ __ ] it's
cuban
and then he took that out of his nostril
and put it in my mouth and he lit it and
i've been smoking cigars ever since
that's the worst [ __ ] story i've ever
heard in my room germaphobe is the best
for anybody you don't have to be a
german that's not how somebody would be
taught how to
he stuck it up his nose and into your
mouth first he saw his dick then he took
a cigar stuck it up his nose is this all
the same day no no over the course of a
couple of years hanging out but why
didn't it bother you that it was from
his nose it was amusing
it was shocking but at this point it was
probably the greatest show business
it was like when people think of show
business stories it's not like from your
nose to my mouth
don't forget i was the young guy in the
steam room at the friars club listening
to these stories what happened in the
steam room jeff
well let me tell you about hannah
youngman
[Music]
you